bonsoir à tous voici les titres de
l'actualité de ce dimanche tout avait
commencé avec la découverte d'un enfant
dans un lac il ya 48 heures sa mère
avait été retrouvée assassinée à son
domicile hier et l' enquête s'est
peut-être terminée aujourd'hui avec
l'arrestation d'un suspect il s'agirait
du compagnon de la jeune femme
la pluie a provoqué un peu partout en
france des inondations de nombreuses
routes ont été coupées la vendée
l'alsace et la gironde ont été
principalement touchées
demain les orages seront encore au
rendez vous sur une majeure partie du
pays la politique après ségolène royal
bertrand delanoë voici maintenant
martine aubry et les reconstructeurs le
congrès du parti socialiste prépare et
la députée maire de lille souhaite faire
entendre sa voix et sa différence
reste à savoir jusqu'où ira-t-elle nous
verrons qui était à ses côtés
aujourd'hui à paris
courir le 100 m en 9 secondes et 72
centièmes c'est ce qu'a réalisé hier
soir usain bolt un jeune jamaïcain qui
les tient désormais le nouveau record du
monde de l'épreuve reine de l'athlétisme
il a donné rendez-vous à ses adversaires
aux jo de pékin
enfin connaissez-vous vraiment jean
claude van damme
eh bien peut-être phare finalement si
vous n'avez pas vu son dernier film le
titre jcvd
l'acteur y joue son propre rôle décalé
et étonnant il est notre invité à
interviewer rencontre à la fin de ce
journal à tout à l'heure
merci d'être avec nous comment ce
journal par ce fait divers qui durant
trois jours et aller de rebondissements
en rebondissements et c'est désormais un
homme qui est au coeur de toutes les
questions il est soupçonné d'avoir
assassiné la mère du petit antoine avant
d'avoir jeté l'enfant dans un lac il
s'agit de l'ancien compagnon de la jeune
femme et il a été interpellé dans
l'après-midi françois privat claire
marie denis l'ex-concubin de la victime
vient d'être interpellée dans le calme
par une quinzaine de gendarmes
il est 13h30 âgé de 29 ans connu des
services de police et de gendarmerie
l'homme appartient à la communauté des
gens du voyage les exerce la profession
de ferrailleurs
depuis quelques temps il était logé par
l'un de ses amis dans un appartement du
centre de saint-hilaire de riez une
petite station balnéaire vendéenne
l'interpellation qui a eu lieu tout à
l'heure a été suivi de la mise en garde
à vue du concubin de la maman du petit
antoine
les perquisitions sont encore en cours
dans diverses endroits les police
technique et scientifique sont en cours
également dans plusieurs endroits
donc tout cela va de pair dans les
locaux de la gendarmerie de challans les
auditions peuvent enfin commencer un
travail de vérification et de
recoupements pour tenter de confondre
celui qui est accusé par le petit
antoine de l'avoir précipitée dans le
lac d'apremont
la voiture dans laquelle l'enfant a
probablement été transportée va être
minutieusement examinée par les
gendarmes expert en investigation
criminelle dans la commune du bois de
céné le meurtre de la fille du maire a
bouleversé la majorité des 1400
habitants
mais ici par pudeur et respect on parle
peu quand on a su l'histoire ça vous
coupe les jambes quand même autour de la
maison de la jeune femme
les investigations viennent de s'achever
désormais les enquêteurs tentent de
reconstituer l'emploi du temps précis
des derniers jours de la victime
dont le décès remonterait à jeudi soir
et on retrouve notre envoyé spécial à
challans loïc de la mornais bonsoir loïc
on l'a bien compris tout ce qu'on sente
ce soir sur un seul homme oui
effectivement laurent ici en début
d'après-midi à challans nous avons vu
passer en trombe le convoi des
enquêteurs qui ramenait deux suspects
deux personnes interpellées
la première d'entre elles est ici à la
gendarmerie il s'agit donc de l'ami de
la personne qui hébergeait le concubin
mais pour l'instant cette personne est
toujours entendus comme témoins elle
n'est pas mise en garde à vue et il ne
semble pas que la piste s'oriente vers
une complicité en revanche la deuxième
personne le concubin de la mère du petit
antoine
et bien désormais le suspect numéro 1 il
est en garde à vue françois prix va vous
a indiqué qu'il s'agissait d'une
personne d'une trentaine d'années qui
était ferrailleur qui semble être connu
des services de police et de gendarmerie
la voiture dans laquelle ils auraient
éventuellement transporter le petit
antoine a donc également été saisis et
puis on nous indique ici que l' enquête
va continuer certainement aller très
vite mais nous n'aurons pas de nouvelles
informations avant la fin théorique de
la garde à vue
en revanche on en sait aujourd'hui un
petit peu plus sur la manière dont le
petit antoine a fait ces confidences aux
enquêteurs ce matin il leur a donc
confirmé que le couple que sa maman et
son compagnon s'était séparé il ya une
quinzaine de jours environ
il semble avoir confirmé également une
dispute la nuit du drame et il a donc
évidemment confirmer que c'est bien le
concubin de sa maman qui l'avait emmené
à 30 kilomètres de chez lui en pyjama
puis jetés dans le lac
dernière précision ce sont les
enquêteurs qui ce matin eu la lourde
tâche d'informer le petit garçon du
décès de sa maman
tout simplement parce que le petit
antoine à la télévision dans sa chambre
et que les gendarmes ne voulais pas
qu'ils l'apprennent en regardant les
journaux télévisés
merci loïc et hasard du calendrier c'est
aujourd'hui 1er juin 2008 qu'entre en
vigueur en france une nouvelle règle de
procédure criminelle
l'enregistrement vidéo des auditions et
des gardes à vue pour le moment 75% des
juges d'instruction serait équipé
comment les choses vont dès lors se
dérouler on voit tout cela avec famille
stand l'air et marées crocs
derrière ces murs les gendarmes de
challans inaugure une toute nouvelle
procédure pour la première fois des
gardes à vue majeurs soupçonnés de
crimes sont filmés durant leurs
auditions sur le bureau de l'enquêteur
une webcam un troisième oeil qui
s'ajoute à la procédure écrit
l'enquêteur reçoit l'agresseur devant
lui il va procéder à une audition sur
procès verbal
tout simplement à l'aide d'une webcam
qui va filmer le gardé à vue et grâce au
logiciel on va graver sur un support
numérique sur un cd toute cette audition
une procédure qui existe déjà pour les
mineurs délinquants depuis 2007
enquêteurs a toujours connu cette façon
de travailler
selon lui la caméra n'a jamais troublé
une audition on est obligés d'oublier
parce que si pour avoir ce que c'est la
confiance avec la personne qui en fera
ce que vous avez le droit de couper
l'enregistrement nom de toute manière
tout est au niveau du logiciel dès que
ces coupes et il ya un rapport qui sort
à la fin et on voit que ça a été coupée
même procédure dans le bureau de ce
magistrat pour ce juge d'instruction
c'est une révolution lui aussi devra en
plus de l'écrit enregistré par vidéo les
auditions des mises en examen
une procédure loin d'être inutile il l'a
déjà expérimenté ça m'est déjà arrivé
une fois de de re visionner avec un
mineur un film où il indiquait qu'il
était frappé pendant le temps de son
audition or l'audition était filmé
puisqu'il était mineur et ensemble on a
constaté qu'ils étaient parfaitement
avachi sur son siège et répondait très
calmement aux aux services de police et
à leurs questions c'est après l' affaire
d'outreau et ces manquements que cette
loi a été décidé ces vidéos pourront à
l'avenir être visionné lors des procès
d'assises et permettre ainsi de vérifier
la bonne foi de toutes les parties en
présence dans l'actualité de ces
dernières heures encore et toujours les
fortes pluies dans l'est dans l'ouest du
pays des précipitations aux multiples
conséquences route barret maisons et
caves inondées un ter dans le jeu
a déraillé et un homme a même perdu la
vie à libourne
la nuit dernière ont fait le point avec
jérôme berlin et nos bureaux en région
voici ce que l'on a pu voir hier soir
dans des dizaines de villages en france
les mêmes scènes de torrents d'eau et de
boue
ici à war et dans la vienne toute la
nuit des pompiers débordés ont tenté de
rassurer au matin on évacue comme on peu
ce qu'il reste debout
quelques heures auparavant l'eau
atteignait ici un bon mètre comme
l'indiquent la trace sur le mur dans
cette commune près de hof il est tombé
30 centimètres de pluies dans la journée
dans la maison tout en sueur qui rit
grosses et les chiens c'est tout on
n'avait jamais vu ça
un peu plus loin
même la ligne ferroviaire n'a pas
résisté un petit ruisseau devenu
déchaînée a fait dérailler ce train sans
qu aucun des vingt passagers ne soit
blessé
si les orages se sont abattus un peu
partout en france ces sept départements
ont été les plus touchées ici dans
l'indre et loire
on pourrait croire un bombardement il
s'agit pourtant bien d'inondation des
canalisations exploser des routes
départementales pulvérisé ce lotissement
près de bordeaux a été engloutie sous un
mètre d'eau pas une mais deux fois une
décrue que ça déstabilise et quand il
asséné à beaucoup pleuvoir ses remontées
mais pire qu'hier soir ça n'a rien à
voir c'est assez lamentable qu'on soit
là tout perdu c'est également ici à
libourne que le corps d'un homme âgé de
79 ans a été découvert dans sa cave
inondée
ce monsieur en voulant faire comme à
chaque fois qu'il y avait eu une
inondation il vous l'a voulu et q mais
c'est un certain monsieur qui avait des
problèmes cardiaques et l'a fait un
malaise il est tombé on a essayé de lui
porter secours jusqu'à ce que le samu
arrivent massage cardiaque bouche à
bouche mais ya rien eu à faire le pauvre
est décédée elle déjà touché la veille
l'alsace a été une nouvelle fois frappé
à strasbourg depuis deux jours il pleut
dans la gare tout neuf mais pas tout à
fait étanche 300 mètres cubes d'eau
s'ils étaient infiltrés et attention
pour les prochaines heures météo france
prévoit à nouveau des orages sur une
grande partie du pays
dans l'actualité également la mort
étrange d'un syndicaliste en corse la
nuit dernière l'homme a fait une chute
de deux étages à l'hôpital d'ajaccio un
hôpital en plein conflit social les
faits sont troublants le parquet a
ouvert une enquête bernard lebrun à la
fenêtre
un enquêteur de la police judiciaire le
syndicaliste est il tombé tout seul en
voulant accroché une banderole ou at il
été poussé
une certitude lire ce bâtiment
administratif de l'hôpital où un conflit
social oppose les salariés la direction
était occupé par des syndicalistes
pierre khodja dont voici la photo 43 ans
membre du syndicat des travailleurs
corses chef cuisinier à l'hôpital est
décédée suite à cette chute du deuxième
étage
dès cette nuit l'émotion était grande
dans la cour de l'établissement
proches de la mouvance nationaliste et
sportifs de haut niveau
la victime était bien connue ajaccio
selon le préfet de corse christian
leyrit que l'on voit ici au moment des
faits il n'y avait pas de réunion de
négociation mais uniquement une
occupation en cours par le personnel
craignant d'être délogés par les forces
de l'ordre
les occupants ont empêché la police
cette nuit d'accéder sur les lieux
accident au crime
le procureur de la république d'ajaccio
a ouvert une enquête judiciaire et
demandé dès lundi l'autopsié de la
victime
plus de 240 ont été vandalisés cette
nuit dans un cimetière près de perpignan
la ministre de l'intérieur a souhaité
que toute la lumière soit faite sur
cette affaire
les inscriptions satanistes ont été
retrouvés sur les pierres tombales sur
place reportage veronica guillaume
françois mazou dès qu'elles ont appris
la nouvelle les familles sont venues
voir les tombes de leurs proches sans
comprendre ça nous avance à quoi ceux du
non respect sais je sais pas je n'ai pas
de mots pour vous dire à 5,6 à jemeppe
admire les ja ont été enterrés longtemps
c'est pas peu dire le pape qui pourrait
à vouloir moi je crois que c'est gratuit
2 148 tombes ont été dégradées dans la
nuit ni cassé ni ouverte mais des signes
satanique qui ont été tagués les fleurs
renversés des actes apparemment bien
préparé c'est vraiment quelque chose au
secteur les jeunes de la commune natale
je ne dis pas ça tu as créé pas à ça
mais mais
on recense verheyde on verrait des
mégots des canettes on aurait trouvé les
bons et c'est là on voit bien que c'est
pas du tout ça
le petit cimetière dell a peut-être été
choisi parce qu'il est isolé sans vis à
vis les empreintes les traces de pas ont
été relevés ce matin par les enquêteurs
qui ne connaissent dans la région aucune
vraie mouvance satanique à l'étranger
aux états unis nous entrons dans la
dernière semaine des primaires
démocrates sur le plan comptable les
jeux sont faits barack obama est en tête
mais hillary clinton utilise toutes les
armes toutes les procédures pour
entretenir l'espoir de son investiture à
washington
alain de chalvron tweet jaune habillé
hillary clinton a été à l'église ce
matin porto rico l'étape du jour dans la
course des primaires
une intervention divine c'est bien
désormais la seule chose qui pourrait la
sauver
dans la course à la nomination démocrate
le comité national du parti a tué dans
l'oeuf hier son dernier espoir de
dépasser son rival barack obama il lui
donne en partie satisfaction en lui
attribuant la moitié des délégués
qu'elle revendiquait en floride et le
michigan
2 et a sanctionné pour avoir désobéi aux
règles du parti
si vous trouver une meilleure solution
qu'une compagnie dont m saubi la moitié
c'est bien mais ça n'est pas suffisant
pour relancer la candidate les partisans
d'hillary ont bruyamment fait connaître
leur déception en criant denver denver
c'est à dire en menaçant de porter l
affaire devant la convention du parti à
denver dans le colorado fin août menace
reprises par le délégué officiel de la
candidate
madame clinton m'a chargé de vous dire
qu'elle se réservait le droit de faire
appel
depuis elle est chose que les chiffres
pourtant sont là barack obama n'est plus
qu'à soixante sept délégués de la
majorité absolue alors qu'il en faudrait
encore 242 à hillary un objectif
quasiment hors d'atteinte
même si l'ex première dame continue à
faire campagne
comme si de rien n'était et on retrouve
alain de chalvron à washington bonsoir
alain les deux dernières primaires sont
prévues ce mardi les jeux semblent faits
mais hillary clinton elle continue alors
pourquoi et bien officiellement parce
qu'elle ne désespère pas de pouvoir
convaincre les super délégué vous savez
ces classiques du parti qui ont une
liberté de choix jusqu'au dernier moment
et bien qu'elle est tout simplement la
meilleure la plus à même de battre john
mccain alors les mauvaises langues
disent que si elle continue sa campagne
c'est qu'elles pensent qu un sérieux
pépin pourrait arriver à barack obama
voire même son assassinat il l'a évoqué
vous savez il ya une semaine les très
mauvaises langues disent qu'en
prolongeant ainsi la campagne
indéfiniment ce qu'elle souhaite surtout
c'est faire échouer barack obama de
façon à être dans quatre ans la
candidate naturelle du parti c'est un
jeu un peu dangereux parce qu'on
pourrait aussi lui reprocher et enfin
plus prosaïquement il est surtout
probable qu'elle cherche à négocier une
sortie honorable en ce moment avec un
poste intéressant
leader du groupe démocrate au sénat par
exemple vous même vice présidente et
surtout la garantie qu'on va éponger les
dettes de sa campagne 30 millions de
dollars à peu près dont une bonne partie
sur sa cassette personnelle
merci à l'un et à bientôt les leaders de
la planète se réuniront à partir de
mardi à à rome pour tenter de trouver
des solutions à la crise alimentaire
mondiale
au coeur de cette crise la flambée des
prix des matières premières prenons ce
soir l'exemple de l'un des plus gros
producteurs de riz au monde l'inde
le riz est là bas à la base de
l'alimentation son prix ne cessent de
grimper et les autorités ont même stoppé
les exportations voyons pourquoi avec
notre correspondant arnauld miguet et
fabrice launay les petits singes de
délits se moque bien de cette crise
alimentaire pourtant dans ce temple
hindou dédié au dieu singe à newman les
vendeurs d'offrandes m'ont jamais vu ça
les gens viennent faire des offrandes
aux dieux enfin avant ils l'achetaient 5
kg aujourd'hui ne peuvent en acheter que
deux ou trois
même les dieux ne sont pas à l'abri les
simples mortels doivent se serrer la
ceinture
étranglé par l'augmentation des prix
pourtant l'inde a pris des mesures
draconiennes
elle a interdit toute exportation et
surveille de très près ces réserves avec
un discours toutefois puissant il n'y a
pas de problème de riz dans ce pays''
aucun problème pour le moment pas de
problème
pourtant les stocks diminuent à vue
d'oeil et l'homme de la rue en pâtit ils
sont 300 millions d'indiens à vivre avec
moins de 64 centimes d'euro par jour
alors quand les prix s'envolent c'est
plus d'un tiers de la population qui est
touchée comme kuma en temps normal elle
bénéficie de riz subventionné et depuis
la crise elle doit acheter comme tout le
monde sur le marché où le prix de la
nourriture a plus que doublé
d'habitude j'achète du riz subventionné
mais il n'y en a plus si j'achète un
stylo dry avec cette augmentation de 20%
que mon but je me fasse et l'avenir est
loin d'être rose dans ce contexte de
crise internationale encore aggravée par
les récentes catastrophes naturelles
prenez l'exemple de la birmanie un des
plus importants producteurs de riz se
paye alimente la planète mais comme sa
production est affectée par le cyclone
les marchés mondiaux vont continuer de
flamber comme kuma les classes
populaires accuse le coup l'inde connaît
aujourd'hui une inflation record puis de
8 % un an des législatives le
gouvernement tente de faire tout ce qui
est en son pouvoir pour contrôler cette
flambée inattendue des prix car tout le
monde sait que c'est sur cet enjeu que
se gagneront ils se perdront les
prochaines élections
la situation s'améliore en irak voilà le
point de vue de bernard kouchner qui
était en visite dans le pays ces
dernières 48 heures le ministre des
affaires étrangères qui a d'ailleurs
incité les entreprises françaises à
revenir investir sur le territoire
irakien sur place reportage renaud
bernard et and one
ce n'est pas le pays les amazones
pourtant au kurdistan pas de violence
pas d'attentats alors pour
l'inauguration du consulat bernard
kouchner demande à son diplomate de
jouer les éclaireurs pour les
entreprises françaises
il faut que la france vienne que les
investisseurs viennent que les
professeurs de français viennent que les
autres viennent bernard kouchner n'est
jamais aussi à l'aise que dans les zones
à risque
alors pour atterrir à bagdad il fait
imposer d'assaut la capitale irakienne
n'est pas le kurdistan mais il vient
vérifier que depuis un an
la violence il a été divisé par quatre
il faut maintenant que l'opinion se
rendent compte que les joueurs évoluent
en irak avec l'homme le plus protégé du
pays
on parle encore business parce que la
france veut participer à la
reconstruction
oubliée la brouille avec washington moi
qui suis marié à une femme de neuilly
sur seine
je suis très content de ce changement
les contrats bernard kouchner veut aller
les chercher là où personne ne va à 350
km au sud de bagdad
c'est le pays de l'or noir et avec
l'envolée du cours du pétrole les chefs
de tribus ont tous des millions de
dollars à dépenser de france apporte
cette approche de construction
d'investissement pour séduire les
investisseurs les irakiens propose même
de remonter le temps la pyramide ndour
six mille ans d'histoire ici aurait vécu
le prophète abraham vont penser que le
futur sera bâti sur 6000 similan et de
civilisation après avoir ouvert un
consulat au kurdistan au nord du pays
la france s'apprête à ouvrir une
représentation au sud
ici en plein territoire chiite la
politique en france avec une question
qui sont les reconstructeurs au parti
socialiste il s'était donné rendez vous
aujourd'hui à paris ils ont en commun
par avant de proposer une alternative au
duel annoncé entre ségolène royal et
bertrand delanoë
une personnalité a attiré
particulièrement l'attention aujourd'hui
c'est martine aubry
reste à voir si elle pourrait incarner à
terme la synthèse de toutes les
sensibilités présente aujourd'hui lors
de cette réunion
helen hughes christophe cac
le retour en force de martine aubry
après huit ans d'absence sur la scène
nationale voilà la maire de lille
déterminé à rejouer un rôle pour
reconstruire le parti socialiste et nous
allons le faire collectivement
un collectif qui regroupe des
socialistes aussi différents que laurent
fabius arnaud montebourg ou les amis de
dominique strauss jan objectif affiché
trouver une troisième voie entre
bertrand delanoë et ségolène royal les
français alors qu'il s'interroge sur
notre crédibilité
donc un seul spectacle c'est la reprise
de la guerre des chefs
je vais vous dire chers camarades les
reconstructeurs sont d'abord une force
d'interposition
alors évidemment pas question de parler
de chef chez les reconstructeurs
pourtant un nom fait déjà presque
l'unanimité
martin responsable beaucoup d'expérience
de volonté on n'allait pas encore là
mais en plus on a décidé je voulais
travailler collectif
seule réserve celle de pierre moscovici
lui même candidat déclaré au poste de
premier secrétaire
je suis pas venu ici pour adouber un
troisième présidentiable après avoir dit
que
je n'étais pas pour la désignation d'un
présidentiable à martine aubry devant un
millier de militants chacun expose sa
vision du socialisme
il revient à martine aubry de conclure
non sans une pique à chacun de ses
adversaires
nous sommes pour la liberté la
solidarité et l'égalité parce que nous
sommes socialistes ça se suffit à soi
même et ceux qui ont honte de le dire
eh bien ils n'ont rien à faire dans
notre partie aujourd'hui
voilà pour le libéralisme de bertrand
delanoë et voilà maintenant pour la
démocratie participative de ségolène
royal politique c'est quoi tout
simplement mettre en avant des valeurs
mais c'est aussi donner une vision
donner un sens pas demander à chacun ce
qu'il veut pour pouvoir s'engager
derrière lui des socialistes marchant
vers un même but
l'image est rare mais le chemin est
encore long jusqu'au congrès de novembre
et on n'était pas présent lors de cette
réunion c'est manuel valls non pas pour
des raisons d'agenda mais par choix
celui ci ne croit pas en l'idée de ce
rassemblement le député maire d'evry
était l'invité de 13h15 le dimanche
l'occasion pour lui de revenir sur la
stratégie d'alliance du parti socialiste
on les écoute
comment pouvons-nous nous allier avec
ceux qui ne veulent pas gouverner qui
sont certes sympathie populaire mais qui
ne font que passer pour les 160 la mère
patrie populaire évidemment d'accord
la différence entre lui et nous c'est
entre ceux qui proclament et ceux qui
veulent mettre les mains dans le
cambouis pour changer véritablement la
réalité de la vie des gens ce que vivent
les gens ce que nous demandent les gens
termes de pouvoir d'achat de sécurité
d'avenir pour leurs enfants de retraite
ce sont des solutions concrètes c'est
pas les discours généraux françois
bayrou françois bayroux a mené une
campagne intéressante est un homme
courageux sol n'est au fond au son
projet c'est de nous remplacer c'est de
construire son destin sur l'échec de
nicolas sarkozy et sur les décomptes du
parti socialiste le grand format de ce
soir est une enquête sur une arnaque
dont les victimes sont des nouveaux
propriétaires ils pensent avoir fait
leurs achats s'apprête à vivre dans leur
nouvel appartement
seulement problème celui ci est occupé
par des locataires des locataires de
bonne foi qui ont signé un bail avec un
propriétaire fictifs
vous allez tout comprendre avec franck
gêne au zoo et francis forget
de rage et pour alerter les voisins il a
tagué sa propre maison il y a deux mois
pierre samuel devient propriétaire de ce
duplex vétusté inoccupés quelques jours
plus tard il s'y rend pour évaluer les
travaux à effectuer
il ya une personne qui m'a qui m'a
ouvert devant cette porte et qui m'a dit
qu'elle était locataire de ce lieu
depuis plus de 48 heures je dirige des
propriétaires des maisons à l'intérieur
mohamed attia sa femme et ses cinq
enfants
bonjour bonjour vous êtes qui m'a dit
j'y suis docteur judy gisement j'habite
ici
j'appelle la police elle m'a dit c'est
une affaire privée
c'est du civil si cette personne a en
effet une quittance ds depuis plus de 48
heures et qu'elle est
bye eh bien elle est domiciliée dans cet
endroit
donc vous êtes propriétaire mais là
personnel c'est son domicile si la
police ne peut rien faire c'est parce
que les locataires sont peut-être de
bonne foi en france depuis 10 ans la
petite famille passe d' hôtel social en
hôtel social
le père explique que quelques jours plus
tôt dans un café quand un homme lui
propose de lui louer sa maison il
accepte et signe ce qu'il croit être un
bail en bonne et due forme
j'entrais ce blabla fonds s'est pas
cassé la fenêtre
jean terrible de la porte jpeg acompte
après moi habitent ici
juppé 1800 euros spèce dans la case
bailleur un faux nom une adresse qui
n'existe pas
conclusion un arnaqueur désormais
introuvable deux victimes d en parler
d'eux et les miss you on va essayer de
facile à ranger ensemble ce type d'
arnaque n'est pas nouveau mais face à la
crise du logement il est en forte
recrudescence
d'autant qu'il est difficile de
distinguer une victime d'un squatteur
mal on a plutôt affaire à des systèmes
un peu de filières organisées qui savent
tout à fait ce qu'ils font les risques
qu'ils prennent c'est à dire quasiment
nul puisque là dans tout le monde est
innocent
personne n'a fait quoi que ce soit et
tout le monde est soi disant victime de
la confiance qu'il a pu faire un autre
procès puis procédure d'expulsion
les propriétaires ne récupèrent leurs
biens parfois qu'au bout de deux ans
d'où une tentation de plus en plus
fréquentes
donner de l'argent pour que les faux
locataires s'en aille
vaut mieux négocier données même
quelques centaines ou quelques milliers
d'euros
de toute façon c'est à peu près ce que
ça coûtera pour mener une procédure
d'expulsion à bien avec les frais les
frais de procédure et tout donc des
accords à l'amiable parfois proche du
racket
mohamed attia lui a décidé de quitter la
maison pour prouver sa bonne foi dit il
et ne pas passer pour un voleur il a
refusé de retourner dans un centre
d'hébergement d'urgence installé avec
toutes ses affaires
à quelques mètres de son éphémère maison
cela fait désormais trois semaines que
sa famille et lui dorment dans la rue
voilà pour cette enquête le sport ce
dimanche avec un triste après-midi pour
les français à roland garros entre les
averses défaite de paul henri mathieu
mais également de michaël llodra ont
fait le point sur cette journée avec
julien bénéteau et chloé cormery les
conseils secret de mats wilander
ancien vainqueur de roland garros n'ont
donc pas suffi
paul henri mathieu s'arrêtent en 8e de
finale battu par le serbe novak djokovic
pourtant le français fait jeu égal tout
au long du match avec le numéro 3
mondial
mais djokovic vainqueur de l'open
d'australie fait la différence dans les
points cruciaux
enfin deux sets 6 4 6 3 6 4
il ne manque pas grand-chose à mathieu
mais il n'a toujours pas atteint les
quarts de finale d'un grand chelem
un petit peu moins bien joué que
d'habitude ça c'est sûr mais je pense
que lui l'a fait un match très très
solide de db la fin il n'a pas lâché un
point elle était très très régulier au
niveau de service il y avait de la
vivacité dans l'échauffement de michaël
llodra adepte du service volée contre le
letton gulbis en huitièmes de finale le
parisien offre quelques fulgurances mais
son tennis d'attaqué n'a pas gêné son
jeune adversaire qui était encore à
l'université l'année dernière
llodra est battue en trois sets par le
80e joueur mondial rageant une
impression d'avoir très bien joué donc
forcément j'aurais aimé que ce soit
meilleur mais bon je tombé sur un très
bon joueur aujourd'hui il m'a pas
facilité la tâche mais bon ça fait
partie de la vie j'ai envie de la
journée noire pour les bleus mais avec
chardy benneteau et mon fils la france a
encore trois belles chances de voir les
quarts de finale il s'appelle hussein
bolt et retenez bien son nom si vous
aimez l'athlétisme car il désormais
l'homme le plus rapide au monde sur 100
m jamaïcain âgé de 21 ans est la cause
la distance hier à new york en 9
secondes et 72 centièmes
il rêve désormais d'or olympique à pékin
nathanaël de rincquesen a priori le
temps était plus propice à l'apparition
des escargots
pourtant sur cette piste new yorkaise
c'est l'homme le plus rapide du monde
qui a pointé le bout de son nez avec son
maillot blanc al ahly numéro 4 usain
bolt à 1100 mètres et 9 secondes 72
centièmes pour entrer dans l'histoire du
sport
c'est le record du monde de l'épreuve
reine de l'athlétisme
hier soir il a surpris tout le monde ses
adversaires le public et même les
commentateurs de la télévision
américaine qui retransmettait ce meeting
sous ces par l'émotion et peut être
aussi emporté par son élan bolt mais
plusieurs centaines de mètres à
s'arrêter
ils savent au fond exploit avant d'aller
poser devant le chrono du stade pour
immortaliser l'événement
désormais l'homme le plus rapide du
monde c'est lui décidément bolt ne perd
pas de temps dès la sortie du stade
il fonce dans les rues de new york faire
quelques photos avec change qu on sort
le coureur jamaïcain était inconnu du
grand public
désormais c'est une star je savais qu'en
prenant un bon départ j'avais une chance
la piste était rapide
je suis ravi de ma performance
aujourd'hui encore quelques photos pour
ces nouveaux admirateurs
bolt doit retourner s'entraîner dans
deux mois il devra confirmer sur la
piste de pékin
sébastien loeb a remporté le rallye de
l'acropole à athènes le pilote au volant
de sa citroën a repris la tête du
championnat du monde des pilotes au
finlandais hirvonen la page cinéma tu ce
dimanche avec un film qui en a surpris
plus d'un un film sur jean claude van
damme avec jean claude van damme et oui
l'acteur joue son propre rôle et se
confie face à la caméra un scénario
étonnant et décalé jcvd est avec nous
mais avant de le retrouver
le film de mabrouk el mechri vue par
nicolas le marinier et philippe turpault
oui madame jean claude van damme dans un
polar sombre style années 70
qui l'eût cru
dans jcvd l'acteur belge joue son propre
rôle en se rendant dans une poste il est
pris en otage
c'est le prétexte pour raconter 15 ans
de galère d'argent c'est roule mal
choisi ses interviews des morceaux
d'anthologie courant j'ai pas de cash
sur moi jean claude van damme s'en cache
au vallon train mais ça va pas pendant
une heure trente gendarmes navigue entre
fiction et autoportraits à travers ce
polar le plus hollywoodien des acteurs
belges raconte son parcours chaotique
avec beaucoup de recul et d'humour
bref s'il tourne une page quand je les
rencontre et j'ai vraiment eu la
sensation qui il arrivait à la fin de ce
cycle est que justement et vous les
reconnaître ou en tout cas à passer à
autre chose et et que le film était une
vraie opportunité pour ça donc
finalement lui en tant qu'acteur et moi
en tant que metteur en scène on en a
profiter un petit peu de de son
ras-le-bol justement qu'il faut temps
pour lui d
aujourd'hui drôle et émouvant avec ce
fils jean claude van damme met à mal le
cliché du monsieur muscle sans cervelle
jcvd
c'est le film de sa renaissance
bonsoir jean claude van damme merci nous
de devoir casquer ça a été votre
réaction
lorsqu'on vous a proposé un film sur
vous pas trop facile mais étonné surpris
quand même parce qu'il faut être assez
une certaine biographie de ma vie du
passé et grâce à ça j'ai pu garder une
certaine réalité sous mon caractère
et puis on est rentré sur une histoire
de fiction donc c'est ça qui est dedans
c'est que ça mélange la fiction et puis
des éléments votre biographie voilà et
après donc dans ce film pendant dans
cette fiction on est ressortis dans un
une sorte d'ouverture à l'écran
d'ouverture hagopian sait on verra bien
ces gens bons associés il ya une scène
major où on vous retrouve face à la
caméra ou vous témoigner vous revenez
sur mes moments de votre vie une vraie
sincérité dans cette séquence est assez
étonnant ça a été difficile à tourner ce
moment oui et non parce que bon c'est
pas tellement en fait c'est la vérité on
se rappelle toujours d'une certaine
vérité donc ce qui m'a beaucoup aidé
c'est que
le réalisateur mabrouk a pu donc
vraiment isolé pour cette simple on le
verra donc dans le film il ya quelque
chose qui se passe où je suis donc tout
à fait désolé et je peux parler disons à
dunham et à l'écran d'accord donc voila
quoi le prix à payer pour l'enfant
bruxellois la réussite à hollywood il
assez lourd le prix à payer pour cette
réussite tout de même pas vrai bon j'ai
jugé mon parcours où il ya des gens qui
travaillent dès maintenant soit de 6
heures disons que j'ai beaucoup de
chance dans la vie
m quand vous dites à hollywood où on
fait comprendre que vous êtes le maître
du monde et vous finissez par y croire
c'est c'est vrai c'est ça ce système là
il ya tellement de m je suis passé
j'espère que ma carrière donc bien se
passer
j'ai 47 ans et disons que je peux encore
aller pendant dix ans quoi c'était quoi
les moments difficiles c'était la drogue
non c'était c'était un mélange de tout
parce que bon je suis arrivé seul aux
etats-unis et
je respecte très fort l'amitié et il ya
eu des problèmes avec des certains
producteurs et puis des petites
histoires d'amour qui se sont qu'est ce
qui vous a poussé à dire stop à la
drogue à tuchan qu'enfin il ya certaines
personnes je crois que tout le monde
sent quand c'est ça devient très
dangereux
yann
roue de secours qui s'est mis en marche
et grâce à l'entraînement
vu que je me suis entraîné depuis l'âge
de 11 ans j'ai donc je suis parti à la
salle de sport et je me sens traîner des
heures et des heures et grâce à
l'entraînement donc pour vous il y aura
eu un avant et un après ce film c'était
une sorte de thérapie ça vous a fait
beaucoup de bien ce film de vous
exprimer différemment
très bonne question parce que quand j'ai
vu le film j'ai vu donc un van damme
normal un acteur puis gilles verlant
assez différent que je connais en tant
que spectateur j'ai vu j'ai vu devant
nam et je me suis dit tiens il ya une
énorme bipolarité entre les deux actes
enfin entre des enfants de la même
personne divisent et dont elle veut dire
qu'on ne verra plus dans les films
d'action ou encore vous êtes entré en
tournée mais si on peut faire des films
de caractère donc ou bien une certaine
donc ils gagneraient l'acting bien et
qu'on fait l'action là on devient on
devient the wall of the screen merci
beaucoup en tout cas votre film sort
s'appelle jcvd ça sort mercredi dans les
salles trafic étonnant merci à vous
d'être venu sur ce plateau je t'en prie
merci beaucoup
et comme chaque dimanche voici
maintenant classement des films au
premier jour de leur sortie cette
semaine en tête et de loin sex and the
city la version cinéma de la série télé
en deuxième position française avec
hafsia espère si césar du meilleur
espoir féminin est cette année pour la
graine et le mulet ensuite maradona par
kusturica un documentaire présenté à
cannes sur la vie du footballeur
footballeur de légende et enfin grace is
gone film sur les difficultés des
familles de soldats tombés au combat en
irak
ces images maintenant spectaculaire qui
nous viennent de los angeles est une
partie des studios de cinéma universal
qui a été ravagée ravagé par les flammes
plus de 200 pompiers ont été mobilisés
ainsi que des hélicoptères bombardiers
d'eau
image donc assez impressionnante voilà
laurent avant de refermer journal je
vous en rappelle l'une des principales
informations dans la sphère du meurtre
de la mère du petit antoine retrouvé
dans un lac
vendée il ya 48 heures un homme a été
interpellé aujourd'hui placé en garde à
vue il est actuellement entendu par les
enquêteurs il s'agit de l'ancien
compagnon de la victime
voilà pour l'essentiel de l'information
de ce week-end merci à vous d'avoir
suivi la météo il avait le martin et le
cinéma avec coup d'éclat à la fiche
pierce brosnan et sa mailhac demain
l'information à 13h c'est élise lucet
20h david pujadas passer une très belle
fin de soirée au revoir
l'info en continu c'est aussi sur france
2 point fr